No,
I don't,
I don't think so.
I think there are too many clashes
within each of the civilizations to talk
about,
um,
a clash of it essentially as each of the
civilizations to describe them.
Um,
uh,
but,
um,
it is true that,
that when,
when I'm fundamentalists or zealots or
Orthodox Ultra Orthodox people take
over,
um,
a,
uh,
country,
then they're there.
They will repress the moderates and the
liberals in their own camp and then we
confront them and that does,
that does look like a kind of us against
them.
Um,
but we always have to remember in those
situations,
the people who've been repressed,
all of the liberal and secular Afghans,
for example,
who,
who survive the Taliban regime,
but we didn't hear from them while the
Taliban were in power,
but they're there and those should be
our,
um,
our allies.
And since we all,
since we always have allies in the other
civilizations,
um,
I think it's a big mistake to try to,
to try to describe it as a kind of war
of,
of unified culture.